corea del norte ha detectado un brote de
una enfermedad gastrointestinal aguda
que afecta a unas 800 familias del
suroeste del país y que se solapa con la
ola de kobe que sufre desde finales de
abril el régimen no ha precisado el tipo
de enfermedad gastrointestinal que es
aquella que se contagia pues a través de
un virus de una bacteria de un parásito
que tiene su origen en el consumo de
agua o de alimentos contaminados con
materia fecal y que por desgracia es muy
común en corea del norte ya que muchas
partes del país el tratamiento de aguas
residuales es algo bien insuficiente o
bien inexistente de hecho el servicio
secreto surcoreano considera que muchos
casos de fiebre que es el término que
emplea el régimen norcoreano para
referirse a los casos sospechosos de
kobe dada su falta de capacidad para
testar podrían ser precisamente síntomas
de enfermedades gastrointestinales
corea del norte viene reportando
diariamente en torno a unos 20 mil casos
sospechosos de kobe de asegura que casi
un 20 por ciento de su población habría
contraído ya estas fiebres en las
últimas 8 semanas un lapso en el que
sólo habrían muerto aparentemente de
kobe unas 73 personas son cifras
totalmente inconsistentes en comparación
con olas de kobe que hemos visto en
otros países y por eso la organizada de
la salud ha pedido por favor a pyongyang
que comparta datos mucho más detallados
a su vez el régimen sigue sin aceptar
oficialmente los ofrecimientos de
donación de vacunas pero la alianza
global para la vacunación gabi asegura
tener constancia de que habría recibido
ya vacunas de china y que estaría
administrando las aunque por el momento
no ha podido ofrecer más detalles al
respecto